Envy is wanting something that someone
else has that you don't jealousy is
fearing that someone is going to take
what you have and so like if you are a
jealous lover it means that you don't
want anyone to talk to the person that
you're with but if you're envious of
someone else's wife they are jealous you
are envious it's I think being precise
with that language also helped me
understand when a competitor comes into
your Market it's actually you're getting
jealous because you don't want them to
take your customers but if you see some
guy on Instagram that you're like man
[__] that guy it might be because they
have something that you don't